Dogs have long been portrayed as humanity's lovable best friends, and anyone who has a dog knows that they're pretty smart, but are they smarter than other animals? What about in comparison to our close evolutionary cousin, the chimpanzee? There's at least one thing dogs can do that chimps can't. Point your finger at a hidden treat, and a dog will immediately follow your cue. Human toddlers can do this, but adult chimpanzees cannot. So what does psychology learn from researching this special skill?
长期以来，狗一直被描绘成人类可爱的好朋友，任何养狗的人都知道它们非常聪明，但它们比其他动物更聪明吗？与我们进化上的近亲黑猩猩相比又如何呢？狗至少有一项黑猩猩做不到的技能。用手指指向一个隐藏的零食，狗会立即跟随你的提示。人类幼儿可以做到这一点，但成年黑猩猩却不能。那么，心理学从研究这种特殊技能中学到了什么？
And what can studying dogs' evolutionary journey from wild wolves to domesticated pets teach us about humanity's history? Welcome to speaking of psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Brian Hare, a professor of evolutionary anthropology, psychology, and neuroscience at Duke University. Dr. Hare also founded and co-directs the Duke Canine Cognition Center. Together with his wife and research partner, Vanessa Woods, he recently published a book called
研究狗从野生狼到家养宠物的进化历程，能让我们了解人类历史的什么信息？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是杜克大学进化人类学、心理学和神经科学教授布莱恩·黑尔博士。黑尔博士还创立并共同管理着杜克犬类认知中心。他和他的妻子兼研究伙伴凡妮莎·伍兹最近出版了一本书，名为
Survival of the Friendliest, which lays out a theory of domestication on a broader scale. They argue that humans, just like dogs, are domesticated animals, bred for friendliness. Domestication causes distinct temperamental, physical, and cognitive changes that are as apparent in humans as they are in dogs. and domestication may be the key to our species evolutionary success, and the reason that homo sapiens survived long after other early human species went extinct. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Hare. Kim, thank you so much. Let's start with your research on dogs, which is where this all began.
《适者生存：最友善者胜出》，书中提出了一个更大范围的驯化理论。他们认为，人类就像狗一样，是经过驯化的动物，为了友善而繁育。驯化会导致明显的性情、生理和认知变化，这些变化在人类身上和在狗身上一样明显。驯化可能是我们物种进化成功的关键，也是智人在其他早期人类物种灭绝后依然存活至今的原因。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，黑尔博士。金，非常感谢。让我们从你对狗的研究开始，这一切就是从那里开始的。
You opened your latest book with an anecdote about your childhood dog, Oreo, and how he provided the spark for your entire line of canine cognition research. Can you talk about that? How did he inspire you? And what did you learn from those first studies? Well, I'm like lots of dog lovers. When you have a best friend, especially when I was a little kid growing up, and I couldn't help but wonder what he was thinking and what was going on his mind. Was he like me? Was he different from me? And what ways was he different? So when I went to college and I found out there are folks who do this for a living who try to get inside the minds of animals and see how they think and that it was really important to understanding humans, I was all ready to do it.
你在最新著作的开头讲了一个关于你童年爱犬奥利奥的故事，以及它是如何激发你整个犬类认知研究方向的。你能谈谈这个吗？它是如何启发你的？你从最初的那些研究中学到了什么？嗯，我和许多爱狗人士一样。当你有一个最好的朋友，特别是我小时候成长过程中，我不禁想知道它在想什么，它的脑子里在发生什么。它像我吗？它和我有什么不同？它在哪些方面与我不同？所以当我上大学时，发现有人以此为生，试图进入动物的内心世界，看看它们是如何思考的，而且这对于理解人类非常重要，我就准备好去做了。
And so Oreo was instrumental in getting our studies of dog cognition started when I was in college. Dogs were not seen as particularly interesting or remarkable. Nobody was really studying there with any great effort. And what happened was my undergraduate advisor, Mike Tomicello, was explaining to me why we were studying chimpanzee gestural communication and their understanding of human gestures. And we were finding that chimpanzees were not. particularly good, as you just outlined in your intro, at understanding human gestures. If we point and try to help them and indicate where something's hidden with our gesture, they're not really good at figuring it out. And kids, nine to 12 months of age, this is crucial for them as a developmental
所以，当我上大学时，奥利奥在启动我们的狗认知研究方面发挥了重要作用。当时狗并没有被认为特别有趣或引人注目。没有人真正投入大量精力去研究它们。事情是这样的，我的本科导师迈克·托马塞洛向我解释了为什么我们要研究黑猩猩的手势交流以及它们对人类手势的理解。我们发现黑猩猩并不擅长理解人类的手势，正如你在开场白中所概述的那样。如果我们指点并试图帮助它们，用手势指出某物隐藏在哪里，它们并不擅长弄明白。而9到12个月大的孩子，这对他们来说是一个关键的
time point as a first window into the minds of others. It's the first way they sort of understand our intentions and know what others want. And so when Mike Tomicelo said to me, only humans do this and it's critical to culture and language development and apes can't. I said, well, I think my dog could do that. I think my dog Oreo does that. And that really is what launched the whole thing. That's, that's amazing. Well, so it's always good to define the terms we're using so everyone understands what we're talking about. What do you mean by domestication? How do animals become domesticated and how scientists studied that over the years? Well, I think when we normally think about domestication, we think about humans controlling animal breeding and animal reproduction.
发育时间点，是了解他人思想的第一个窗口。这是他们理解我们意图并知道他人想要什么的最初方式。所以当迈克·托马塞洛对我说，只有人类能做到这一点，这对文化和语言发展至关重要，而猿类做不到时，我说，嗯，我想我的狗能做到。我想我的狗奥利奥能做到。这确实开启了这一切。这太令人惊奇了。那么，定义我们使用的术语总是好的，这样每个人都能理解我们在谈论什么。你所说的驯化是什么意思？动物是如何被驯化的，科学家多年来是如何研究这一点的？嗯，我认为当我们通常想到驯化时，我们会想到人类控制动物的繁育和繁殖。
And certainly that is a critical part of the story of the animals that we have today that most people would consider domesticated. But there's actually what we think based on some experiments, an earlier stage of domestication that influenced many species and especially is a big part of the story of dog evolution from wolves is. self-domestication. It's when natural selection actually shapes animals and really kind of pushes them in a direction towards what we would recognize as being domesticated. But it's actually just natural selection doing the work, not humans. So I can unpack that for you a little bit, but the idea is that there's really at least two stages of domestication. There's one where
当然，这是我们今天所拥有的、大多数人认为已被驯化的动物故事中的关键部分。但实际上，根据一些实验，我们认为驯化还有一个更早的阶段，它影响了许多物种，尤其是狗从狼进化而来的故事中的重要部分，那就是自我驯化。这是当自然选择实际上塑造了动物，并真正将它们推向我们所认为的“被驯化”的方向时。但实际上，这是自然选择在起作用，而不是人类。我可以为你稍微拆解一下，但核心观点是驯化确实至少有两个阶段。有一个阶段是
natural selection works to shape an animal to be more like a domestic. animal that we would recognize. And then once that occurs, humans recognize that and then start intentionally breeding animals. But in the case of dogs, for instance, all the European dog breeds that we recognize today that are most prevalent in our society, they all were artificially selected only starting about 150, 200 years ago, but dogs evolved as much as 20,000 years ago. So artificial selection can explain the origin. of dogs, even though it explains the breeds we have today. And there are a lot of breeds out there, but let me ask you this question, and I know you get
自然选择致力于将动物塑造成我们所认可的家养动物。一旦这种情况发生，人类就会意识到这一点，然后开始有意识地繁育动物。但以狗为例，我们今天所认可的、在社会中最普遍的所有欧洲犬种，它们都是在150到200年前才开始被人工选择的，但狗早在2万年前就进化出来了。所以人工选择可以解释狗的起源，尽管它解释了我们今天拥有的品种。外面有很多品种，但我问你一个问题，我知道你经常被问到
asked this all the time, and I'm going to do it anyway. Which are smarter, dogs or cats? I do get asked that question a lot. So my answer to that is always if you can tell me if a hammer or a screwdriver is a better tool, I can answer your question about cats and dogs. And I'm not trying to be, because it's a fun question and his tongue and cheek. But I do think, it helps illustrate what cognition is, especially in the world of animal cognition, when we're trying to understand the origin and the evolution of species differences in psychological abilities. A hammer and a screwdriver, they're each designed for different jobs. One is not better than the other because they're apples and oranges, one hammers and one screws screws. And they
这个问题，但我还是要问。狗和猫哪个更聪明？我确实经常被问到这个问题。所以我的回答总是：如果你能告诉我锤子和螺丝刀哪个是更好的工具，我就能回答你关于猫和狗的问题。我并不是想开玩笑，因为这是一个有趣的问题，带有讽刺意味。但我确实认为，这有助于说明什么是认知，特别是在动物认知领域，当我们试图理解心理能力物种差异的起源和进化时。锤子和螺丝刀，它们各自为不同的工作而设计。没有哪一个比另一个更好，因为它们是苹果和橘子，一个用来敲打，一个用来拧螺丝。它们
wouldn't be good at the other job compared to the other tools. So it's the same for animal minds. Animal minds, just like their bodies have been shaped by evolution to promote their reproduction and survival. And so animals have different types of cognition and those different types of cognition can vary independently within a species. And there can be species that have types of cognition that other species don't have. It's foreign because we're so used to thinking about being given some number on a standardized test where I'm, you know, 84 and you're 150, and we can kind of try to boil intelligence down to a number. But it just doesn't work when we back out and think about evolution in different species.
在对方的工作上表现不会好。动物思维也是如此。动物的思维，就像它们的身体一样，是由进化塑造的，以促进它们的繁殖和生存。因此，动物拥有不同类型的认知，这些不同类型的认知可以在物种内部独立变化。有些物种可能拥有其他物种所没有的认知类型。这很陌生，因为我们习惯于认为在标准化测试中被给出一个数字，比如我是84分，你是150分，我们可以试着把智力归结为一个数字。但当我们退后一步，思考不同物种的进化时，这种方法就行不通了。
And anybody who challenges me on this, I typically ask them how they did on their echolocation test. Which then raises the question of, then what's, can you even tell what's the most intelligent non-human animal. And you mentioned echolocation, which makes me think of, say, dolphins. But again, is it just an unfair question? I wouldn't say it's unfair. I would just say that it, I think it reveals there's a much deeper, more interesting question, which is, where does cognition come from? What types of cognition are there? And why is it that some animals have, you know, why do animals have the types of cognitive abilities they have. And so it becomes a lot less interesting to ask who's
任何挑战我这一点的人，我通常会问他们在回声定位测试中表现如何。这就引出了一个问题：那么，你能分辨出哪种非人类动物最聪明吗？你提到了回声定位，这让我想到了海豚。但同样，这是一个不公平的问题吗？我不会说它不公平。我只会说，我认为它揭示了一个更深层、更有趣的问题，那就是：认知从何而来？有哪些类型的认知？为什么动物会拥有它们所拥有的那种认知能力？所以问谁更聪明变得没那么有趣了。我的意思是，你知道，一只在树上的海豚。我的意思是，它不太聪明。黑猩猩钓鱼。它不太聪明。所以一旦你退后一步，开始思考不同的动物，很明显，我们通常思考智力的方式已经不再有意义了。那么犬种之间呢？我有一只6磅重的玩具贵宾犬，当然，它非常聪明，而且非常适应人类的想法，至少这是我作为外行对它的观察。为什么说，有些狗能成功成为服务犬，而另一些却不能？这与品种有关吗？
smarter. I mean, you know, a dolphin in a tree. I mean, it's not very smart. Chimpanzee fishing. It's not very smart. I mean, so as soon as you back out and start thinking about different animals, it's clear that how we normally think about intelligence doesn't really make any sense anymore. What about among dog breeds? I have a six-pound toy poodle who is amazingly smart, of course, and very attuned to what humans think, at least that's my layperson's observation of her. Why is it that, say, some dogs can succeed as service animals and others can't? Does that have something to do with breed?
嗯，我们非常幸运。我们得到了美国国立卫生研究院和海军研究办公室的支持，我们做了大量研究狗心理个体差异的工作。我刚才告诉你，在物种之间问谁更好或更聪明，并没有真正的意义。在物种内部，这稍微有点意义。但同样，我们认为狗可能是我们发表过许多论文的最有力的证明之一，因为我们可以获得足够大的样本量，让我们在狗身上看到这一点。狗实际上拥有不同类型的认知。至少有五六种我们
Well, we've been so lucky. We've been supported by the National Institute of Health and the Office of Naval Research, and we've done a lot of work looking at individual differences in dog psychology. I just told you that between species asking sort of who's better, or smarter, it doesn't really make sense. Within a species, it makes a little bit more sense. But again, we see dogs as probably one of the most powerful demonstrations that we've published a number of papers now because we can get sample sizes that allow us to see this in dogs. That dogs actually have different types of cognition. There are at least five or six that we
已经能够证明。所以我想说的是，你不能用一个因素来解释不同狗之间的个体差异，比如你的狗看起来非常善于社交，而我的狗可能不是，你不能用一个因素来解释这种个体差异。它需要考虑多个方面。具体来说，我们知道狗有一种认知类型，涉及对人类产生共情反应。我们知道它们有另一个因素，涉及在我们做手势时理解我们的交流，另一个因素是记忆力，另一个因素是具有一定的自我控制能力。这些因素，就像思考，你知道，仅仅因为你擅长英语
have been able to demonstrate. So what I'm trying to say is you can't explain individual variability between different dogs, say your dog that seems so social attentive and my dog, who may not be, you can't explain that individual variability with one factor. It requires taking into consideration multiple things. So to be concrete, we know that dogs have a type of cognition that is involved in having empathic response to humans. We know that they have another factor that is involved in understanding our communication when we gesture, another factor for memory. another factor for having some self-control. And those factors, it's like thinking about, you know, just because you're good at English
并不意味着你擅长数学，反之亦然。狗也是一样。所以我们认为这种个体差异就是解释它们个性的原因，我们利用这种个体差异，回到你最初的问题，试图预测哪种认知能力特征和表现环境会预测工作表现，比如作为服务犬，甚至是炸弹探测犬。我们发现了一些非常好的联系。有没有什么技巧可以让我们让狗变得更聪明？嗯，我认为首先要问的是“与什么相比”，这总是我被问到这个问题时喜欢问的有趣问题。因为通常当人们说，哦，我的狗太聪明了，或者我的狗不太聪明。我总是说，嗯，与什么相比？嗯，当然是与我隔壁邻居的狗相比。我认为这是一个很好的比较，因为通常人们会结结巴巴，然后我看到他们的大脑在转动，他们会想，哦，我是在与人做比较。我认为最好的比较是与其他狗相比。当我们这样做时，我们看到狗有不同的认知能力，它们独立变化。实际上，这就是塑造它们个性的原因。一只狗相对于另一只狗有更多的同理心，但与其他狗相比，它们可能不太擅长解读交流手势，也许它们的记忆力不太好，而其他狗有很好的记忆力和交流能力，但同理心没那么强。
doesn't mean you're good at math and vice versa. It's the same with dog. So we think that that individual variability is what explains their personality, and we've used that individual variability to return to your original question to try to predict which type of profile cognitive abilities and sort of the milieu of performance will predict. working performance and as service dogs or even as bomb detecting dogs. And we found some really nice links there. Are there techniques that we can use to make our dogs smarter? Well, I think just the first thing is compared to what is always my fun question when people
所以我们已经能够测量并证明事实确实如此，狗确实存在这种程度的个体差异。你也研究过倭黑猩猩，如果大家不知道它们是什么的话。它们是黑猩猩和人类的表亲，它们不是宠物或牲畜，所以大多数人不会认为它们是家养动物。它们与狗和其他家养动物有什么共同点？嗯，倭黑猩猩和黑猩猩是我们最近的遗传亲属。就像有两个表亲。一个是女孩，一个是男孩，他们和你关系同样亲近，因为他们都是你的表亲，但他们彼此不同。
ask me about that. Because usually when people say, oh, my dog is so smart or my dog is not so smart. I always say, well, compared to what? Well, to my next door neighbor's dog, of course. I think that's a great comparison because usually what people, they sort of stammer and then I see the wheels turning and they're kind of thinking, oh, I was thinking relative to people. And I think the best comparison is with other dogs. And when we do that, we see that dogs have different cognitive abilities and they vary independently. And really, that's what creates their personality. One dog has relative to another dog a lot of empathy, but they may not be that very good at reading communicative gestures compared to other dogs. and maybe their memory is not so good, whereas other dogs have really good memory and communication, but not so much empathy.
所以倭黑猩猩和黑猩猩确实为我们提供了很多关于行为和认知如何改变的见解，因为它们关系非常密切，但它们彼此之间的差异非常有趣。所以从来没有观察到倭黑猩猩杀死另一只倭黑猩猩。黑猩猩在与某些人类群体直接比较时，其杀人或谋杀率与人类相当。所以你有倭黑猩猩，作为我们最近的活体亲属，与我们关系同样亲近，却从不互相残杀。
So we've been able to measure and demonstrate that that is indeed the case, that dogs have that level of individual variability. You've also worked with bonobos, which if everybody doesn't know what they are. They're cousins of chimpanzees and of humans, and they aren't pets or livestock, so most people wouldn't think of them as domesticated animals. What do they have in common with dogs and other domesticated animals? Well, bonobos and chimpanzees are closest genetic living relative. It's like having two first cousins. One's a girl, one's a boy, and they're equally closely related to you because they're both your first cousins, but they're different from each other.
所以，当你把这一点加上它们许多形态确实与黑猩猩有有趣的差异，这表明它们可能受到了非常强烈的友善选择，这与我们认为驱动狗进化的选择压力相同。这是基于一些实验，信不信由你，实际上是关于狐狸和鸡的实验，它们被实验性地驯化了。唯一的选择压力是增加对人的吸引力和友善度。基于这一个标准，狐狸和鸡都变得更友善了，但它们在生命中的许多有趣方面也变得更像婴儿或幼体。它们在生命中保留了一些幼年特征。
So bonobos and chimpanzees really offer us a lot of insight into how behavior and cognition can change because they're so closely related, but they're different from each other in ways that are really interesting. So no bonobo has ever been observed to kill another bonobo. Chimpanzees, in direct comparisons to certain human populations, have homicide or murder at the rate of humans. So you have bonobos that are closest living relative equally closely related to us as chimps who never kill one another.
它们的形态也发生了变化。以狐狸为例，它们最终出现了更多的垂耳、卷尾和不同颜色的皮毛。它们的口鼻部变短了。它们的牙齿变小了一点。这些特征都没有被专门选择，但相对于对照组的狐狸，所有这些变化都发生了。所以当我们观察倭黑猩猩，然后将它们与黑猩猩进行比较时，
And so that then when you take that. on top of the fact that a lot of their morphology really is different from chimpanzees in an interesting way that suggests that they may have been under really strong selection for friendliness, which is the same selection pressure that we think drove dog evolution. And that's based on some experiments with actually foxes and chickens, believe it or not, that were experimentally domesticated. And the only selection pressure was for increase in attraction and friendliness to people. And based on that single criteria, foxes and chickens both become friendlier, but they also become more infant-like or juvenile-like in their behavior in a number of interesting ways throughout their lives. They kind of retain some juvenile traits throughout life.
我们在那些实验种群中因友善而产生的许多变化，在黑猩猩和倭黑猩猩之间也看到了类似的改变。这让我们抓耳挠腮，说，嘿，哇，如果倭黑猩猩攻击性少得多，它们是否经历了友善的选择，从而导致了所有这些特征的改变？我们在这里有一个潜在的解释。说到狐狸，我在我住的地方看到越来越多的狐狸。我在华盛顿特区的郊区，就在几周前，我看到一只狐狸和一只猫坐在我的车道上，互不理睬。这真是太奇怪了。随着人口的扩张，我们占领了这个国家更多以前的荒地，一些动物，如狐狸、鹿、郊狼，正与人进行更密切的接触。我知道你最近发表了一项研究，发现生活在城市附近的郊狼可能正在经历我们一直在谈论的这种对人类友善的进化选择。你能谈谈那项研究以及我们能从中了解到什么吗？当然。我的意思是，我认为倭黑猩猩和郊狼都展示了这一点，我们试图通过观察它们来测试的是回到这种驯化的两种类型，一种是自然选择的结果。由于对狐狸和鸡等的实验，我们知道当你选择友善时，你会得到一整套看起来非常像我们通常认为的驯化的变化。你会得到生物体发育方式的变化。
And their morphology changes. In the case of the foxes, they ended up having. higher levels of floppy ears and curly tails and different colored coats. And they had their muzzles became shorter. Their teeth became a little bit smaller. None of those things were selected for, but relative to a control population of foxes, all those changes occurred. So when we look at bonobos and then compare them to chimpanzees,
这进而改变了它们的行为和外貌。我们在倭黑猩猩身上看到了这种情况。我们认为这是狗起源的一个很好的解释，因为我们知道狗是在与狩猎采集者或觅食人群的互动中进化的，因为2万年前还没有农业。没有理由相信觅食者会出于某种原因主动控制狼的繁殖。这说不通。所以我们认为最友善的狼具有优势，因为它们可以利用人类的垃圾。我们认为更友善的倭黑猩猩具有优势，因为事实证明，你知道，具有攻击性和成为阿尔法雄性代价非常高。
a lot of those changes that occurred in those experimental populations as a result of friendliness. We also see the analogous change between chimps and bonobos. And it made us scratch your head and say, hey, wow, if bonobos are so much less aggressive, have they had selection for friendliness that then caused all the traits to change? And we have a potential explanation here. Speaking of foxes, I see more and more of them out in the world where I live. I'm in the suburbs of Washington, D.C. just a couple of weeks ago, I saw a fox and a cat sitting together in my driveway paying no attention to one another. It was the strangest thing. And as the human population expands and we take over more of the formerly wild land in this country, some animals, foxes, deer, coyotes are coming into closer contact with people. I know you recently published a study that found that coyotes living near cities may actually be undergoing this type of evolutionary selection we've been talking about for friendliness toward humans. Can you talk about that study and what we can learn about that from that? Sure. I mean, I think what the bonobos and the coyotes really both show and what we were trying to test by looking at them is back to this idea of two types of domestication, one that happens as a result of natural selection. And because of the experiments on foxes and chickens, et cetera, we know that when you select for friendliness, you get a whole syndrome of changes that really look a lot like what we normally think of as domestication. And you get changes in how the organism develops.
我们已经能够测量出，最成功的倭黑猩猩雄性的繁殖成功率或后代数量比最成功的阿尔法雄性黑猩猩还要高。所以友善在进化中确实有很大的回报，然后回到你关于像你邻居的狐狸那样生活在我们附近的动物的问题。我们认为，对人类人工制品和人类空间的同样选择和吸引力，现在正在郊狼和狐狸身上上演。它们正在通过自然选择进行自我驯化，因为如果它们能找到与我们和平共处并利用城市景观创造的所有资源的方法，它们也具有优势。你的自我驯化理论如何应用于人类？嗯，如果你能让友善的选择
And that then changes how they behave and what they look like. And we see that happening in bonobos. We see that happening. We think this is a great explanation for the origin of dogs because we know that dogs evolved in interactions with hunter-gatherers or foraging populations because 20,000 years ago there was no agriculture. And there's no reason to believe that foragers would have gone and actively controlled the breeding of wolves for some reason. That doesn't make any sense. And so we think the friendliest wolves were at an advantage because they could take advantage of human garbage. We think bonobos that were friendlier were at an advantage because it ends up, you know, being aggressive and alpha is very costly.
发挥作用，并真正塑造动物的行为、发育和心理，从狗和倭黑猩猩，以及现在在郊狼身上开始出现的证据来看，我认为我们有很好的证据。而且我认为对于像鱼类这样关系遥远的动物也可以提出一个理由。如果这是一个反复发生的过程，即对友善的选择，从而导致思维、大脑、身体的变化，那么我们自己的物种呢？
And we've been able to measure that the bonobo males, the most successful bonobo male has higher reproductive success or more offspring than the most successful alpha male chimpanzee. So friendliness really pays off big in evolution and then turning to your question about animals that live near us like your fox in your neighborhood. We think that that same selection and attraction for human artifacts and humans spaces is playing out with coyotes and foxes right now. And they're being self-domesticated through natural selection because they too are at an advantage if they can find ways to peacefully coexist with us and take advantage of all the resources. that are created by an urban landscape. How does your theory of self-domestication apply to humans? Well, if you can have selection for friendliness,
所以我们花了很多时间思考这个问题。那个“啊哈”时刻是，作为一个在人类学系但从事心理学研究的人，我能够与那些做出重大发现的人互动。我们对人类晚期进化理解的一个重大变化是，在地球上，直到非常非常近的过去，我们的物种并不孤单。所以5万年前，至少还有其他四种人类。所有这些物种都打乱了我们关于为什么我们在这里以及为什么只有人类存活的正常解释。
play out and really shape animal behavior, development, and psychology in species ranging from, and I think we have some nice evidence from dogs and bonobos and now the beginnings of evidence in coyotes. And I think a case can be made for other animals as distantly related as fish. If this is a process that's going on again and again, selection for friendliness, then leading to changes in all mind, brain, body, what about our own species?
因为通常如果你说，嗯，为什么人类与其他动物如此不同？大多数人会说，嗯，我们有语言，我们有文化，你知道，我们有这些大脑袋等等。嗯，猜猜怎么着？所有那四个其他物种也都有所有这些特征。所以这个解释并不能真正解释为什么它们灭绝了而我们没有。事实上，五分之四的物种在拥有这种特征组合的情况下灭绝了。这并不太乐观。那么我们有什么特质让我们能够繁荣和生存呢？我认为这是一个对友善进行选择的过程。由于对友善的选择会导致身体和形态的变化，我们能够在8万年前后的人类化石证据中寻找这些特征。好吧，所以友善提供了进化优势，最友善的人类物种赢得了那场特定的竞赛。但当然，人类也可以对彼此做可怕的事情，战争、酷刑等等。这如何融入“最友善者胜出”的故事中？
And so we spent a long time contemplating that. And the aha moment was as somebody who is in an anthropology department, but doing psychology, I was able to interact with people who were making big discoveries. and one of the big changes in our understanding of late human evolution is that our species was not alone until very, very recently on this planet. So 50,000 years ago, there were at least four other species of humans. And all those species kind of mess up our normal explanation for why we are here and the only human standing.
嗯，是的，这确实有点矛盾。显然，人类有能力做出可怕的事情。那么你如何解释我们既能如此友善，又能如此残忍的事实呢？嗯，我的博士导师是理查德·兰厄姆，他确实是第一个向我指出这个矛盾挑战的人。他很好地总结说，这几乎就像我们是卢梭，在自己的群体成员中，而对于那些不像我们的人，我们是霍布斯。在书中，我们确实接受了这个挑战，并认为发生的事情是，当我们对友善进行选择时。我们基本上发生了一种变化，我们将群体成员视为
Because normally if you say, well, why are humans so different than other animals? Most people would say, well, we have language and we have culture and, you know, we have these big brains, et cetera. Well, guess what? All four of those other species also had all of those traits. So that explanation doesn't really explain why they went extinct and we didn't. In fact, four out of five species went extinct with that combination of traits. It's not very promising. So what is it about us that allowed us to thrive and survive? And I think it was a process of selection for friendliness. And because selection for friendliness leads to changes in the body and morphology, we were able to look for those signatures in fossil evidence of humans before and after the last 80,000 years. Okay, so friendliness provides an evolutionary advantage and the friendliest human species won that particular race. But of course, humans can also do terrible things to each other, war, torture, much more. How does this fit into the story of the survival of the friendliest?
亲属或家人，我们像爱自己的后代或亲属一样爱他们。当你拿任何物种来说，比如熊，一只带着后代的熊，看到一位母亲，一只母熊和它的幼崽玩耍和哺乳，是最温馨的事情。但母熊什么时候最危险？嗯，就是当你介入后代和母熊之间的时候。我认为我们也是一样。当我们爱更多
Well, yeah, it is a little bit paradoxical. Obviously, humans are capable of horrific things. And so how did it then you explain the fact that we can be so friendly, but then we can be so cruel? Well, my PhD advisor was Richard Rangham, and he really was the first to sort of point this out to me, this paradoxical challenge. And he really nicely says it's almost like we are Rousseau at home with our own group members and Hobbs abroad with those that are not like us. And in the books, we really take this challenge on and argue that what happens is when we have selection for friendliness. We basically have a change where we see our group members as if they
人，更多类型的人，我们的群体成员，就像他们是家人一样，嗯，当他们受到威胁时，我们也会感到更受威胁。这使我们有可能做出可怕的事情。所以我们确实深入研究了这种反应的心理学
are kin or their family, and we love them as if they were our offspring or akin. And when you have take any species, but let's just go with a bear, a bear with its offspring, it's the most nurturing thing to see a mom, a mother bear with its cubs playing and nursing. But when is a mother bear most dangerous? Well, it's when you get between the offspring and the mama bear. And I think the same is for us. As we loved more
和神经生物学。我认为我们有一些很好的证据表明，使我们作为一个物种独特地友善并具有超强同情心的相同机制，当它们以某种方式关闭时，也会导致非人化和最恶劣形式的暴力。那么，基于友善更有利于物种生存的理论，我们中间的这些负面特征最终会消失吗？嗯，我的意思是，如果我们是对的，我们就被困住了，因为使我们友善的相同事物也是使我们变得可怕的事物，我的意思是甚至在脑和思维的机制上也是如此。所以这是一个很好的问题。我总是被问到，你知道，嗯，我们不能，如果我们能繁育动物使它们友善，
people, more types of people, our group members, as if they were family, well, we became more threatened when they were threatened. And it allows for us to do potentially horrible things. And so we really take a deep dive into what the psychology
为什么不能繁育人类？当然，你知道，那是通往优生学的捷径，这在道德上是令人反感的。但我们也在这本书中论证了为什么它行不通，因为仅仅根据我们今天对遗传学的了解，人类是一个不寻常的案例，我们的行为在基因上是由数百甚至数千种不同的基因塑造的。所以要真正选择人类，记住我们有70亿人，而狐狸实验只允许大约1%的狐狸繁殖，所以只有1%的人会繁殖，而且我们能以某种方式识别
and neurobiology is of that response. And I think we've got some good evidence that that the exact same mechanisms that allow us to be uniquely friendly as a species and be super compassionate are the same mechanisms when they sort of turn off that allow for things like dehumanization and the worst forms of violence. So might these negative traits among us disappear eventually due to the theory that friendliness is better for survival of the species? Well, I mean, it's kind of a, we're kind of stuck if we're right because the same thing that makes us friendly is the same thing that's the same thing that. makes us horrible, and I mean even mechanistically in the brain and in the mind. And so it is a good question. I always get asked, you know, well, can't we, if we can breed animals to be friendly,
基因，甚至能可靠地测量人类更友善的表型，这是不可能的。它永远不会奏效。所以我认为社会问题确实需要社会解决方案。我不认为繁育和带回优生学是一个，你知道，那是可怕的。我不认为技术是，因为它是一把双刃剑。但我确实认为社会问题需要社会解决方案。而且我确实认为，一旦我们理解了允许我们友善和残忍的机制，外面就有一些非常好的方案。
why not humans? And of course, you know, that's a quick road to eugenics, which is repugnant morally in every way, shape, or form. But also, we argue in the book about why it wouldn't work, because just what we know about genetics today, humans are kind of an unusual case in that our behavior is shaped genetically by literally hundreds and even thousands of different genes. And so to actually select humans, and remember there's seven billion of us, and the fox experiment only allowed about 1% of the foxes to breed, so that only 1% of people were going to reproduce and that somehow we could identify
你现在的研究兴趣在哪里？你接下来要做什么？嗯，当我们开始审视，你知道，试图理解过去的整个练习是为了帮助为未来提供信息。当你通过自我驯化的视角审视人类行为时，它帮助我们得出了结论，
genes and we could even measure a friendlier phenotype reliably in humans, it's impossible. It would never work. So I think social problems do require social solutions. I don't think breeding and bringing back eugenics is a, you know, that's horrible. And I don't think technology is, because it's a double-edged sword. But I do think social problems require social solutions. And I do think there's some really nice ones out there once we understand the mechanism that allows for our friendliness and our cruelty.
哇，我们确实是进化出的最友善的人类，但这种友善伴随着这种阴暗面的代价。一旦我们意识到并能诊断出这一点，我们就可以开始思考解决方案。所以，你知道，我们正在研究如何对人类本性中最糟糕的部分进行免疫的问题。我们最兴奋的事情之一是跨群体友谊，因为有非常好的证据表明，当你拥有跨不同群体的友谊时，它会减少非人化的可能性，它几乎能对此产生免疫。我们现在正在做的有趣的实验，把一切都圆满地
Where are your research interests now? What are you doing next? Well, when we start looking at, you know, the whole exercise of trying to understand the past is to help inform the future. And when you look at human behavior through the lens of this idea of self-domestication, it helped us arrive to the conclusion,
结合起来，是我们有了第一个数据集，我们在杜克大学经营一个幼犬幼儿园，因为我们正在研究如何培养狗成为伟大的服务犬。我们在那里有很多志愿者。我们已经能够证明，人们在与幼犬互动时所产生的接触实际上减少了，或者我应该说，它增加了他们对那些与自己不同的人的人性化。这就是你所说的社会解决方案。是的。哇，那太棒了。好吧，谢谢你今天加入我们，黑尔博士。这真的很有趣，我希望所有将要听这个节目的狗主人都能学到一些东西，甚至读读你的书。非常感谢，金。
wow, we really are the friendliest human that ever evolved, but that friendliness came with a, cost of this darker side. And then once we realize and can diagnose that, then we can start thinking about solutions. And so, you know, we are working on the question of how do you immunize against the worst of human nature? And one of the things we're most excited about is cross-group friendships because there's really nice evidence that when you have friendships across different groups, that it reduces the potential for dehumanization, it almost immunizes against it. And the fun experiment we're doing right now of kind of putting everything together full
你可以在我们的网站 www.combeatingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦尔曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康丁。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
circle is we have our first data set with, we run a puppy kindergarten at Duke because we're studying how to raise dogs to be great service dogs. And we have a lot of volunteers in there. And we've been able to show that the contact that people have as they interact with puppies actually reduces, or I should say it, it increases how they humanize those that are different from themselves. So that's the social solution you're talking about. Yes. Wow, that's all great. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Hare. It's been really interesting, and I hope all the dog owners out there who are going to listen to this will learn something and even read your book. Thank you so much, Kim.
我们有第一组数据，我们在杜克大学开设了一个幼犬幼儿园，因为我们正在研究如何将狗培养成出色的服务犬。我们有很多志愿者参与其中。我们已经能够证明，人们在与幼犬互动时产生的接触，实际上减少了——或者我应该说，它增加了他们将与自己不同的人人性化的程度。所以这就是你所说的社会解决方案。是的。哇，这太棒了。好吧，感谢您今天加入我们，黑尔博士。这真的很有趣，我希望所有收听节目的狗主人都能学到一些东西，甚至去读读您的书。非常感谢，金。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingofpsychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weirman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威尔曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康丁。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。